hey what's going on hot ones fans Sean
Evans coming at you from a boardroom so
you know we're serious we need to talk
whether it's Taco gate or the internet
fashion police coming at my neck for
wearing a style forward cardigan on the
set of hot ones it's been feet to the
fire for two straight years but no
grievance stuffs the complaint box quite
like Sean doesn't know how to eat a
chicken wing Sean doesn't know how to
eat a chicken wing well as anyone who's
watched from those goofball YouTube
tutorials on how to eat chicken wings
knows it's very easy you find the small
bone you wiggle it away you give it a
little twist like so you pull it out
okay this is this is how to eat chicken
wings this is how everyone's doing it
okay so there are two sides to a chicken
wing a skinny side and a fat side find
the side with the bigger protrusion next
to the big bone find the skinnier bone
twist it until it slides out now you're
just left with the big bone jostle that
thing loose twist it slide that on out
and you're left with a nice clean
chicken wing meat pocket so today I'll
try out some of the techniques that have
stood out to me over the first four
seasons who knows maybe I'll adopt a new
approach and then we can all turn the
page first things first let's start with
Bert Kreischer that you guys go at it
like savages just oh my god no
take a lot of wing that is eaten like
this you take it you twist you then take
this bone okay okay you slide it out
this one yeah then you've got basically
like a little meat all right
I like how Bert is very like you guys
eat it like savages and then he
basically ends up with a flat meat stick
that he just shoves down his throat is
that more dignified is that really the
perfect way to eat a wing meanwhile he
ditches his plan after the second or
third wing when you're in a war when
you're in the
middle of hot sauce battle it's any port
in a storm you just get that bite off
and you keep moving because you're in
the foxhole and you're taking on fire
alright here we have Eddie Wong famously
going death sauce first
you are yeah I'm going dumb deep diving
in the deep end I'm just gonna get it
done it's to work ready oh yeah this is
no joke it's a little nippy I mean to go
make a death sauce right off the bat
open up crazy move I think that that was
really more of a move for survival I
don't think that's really how anyone
would eat their wings
he just had death sauce all over his
lips and all over his face so he was
just trying to find the white meat like
an oasis in the desert which one you
think about is actually kind of a good
idea so uh a little uh tip of the cap to
Eddie on that one maybe that's that
right now that's the front-runner it's a
good idea getting to that white meat
ducked that hot sauce alright here we
got the old garyvee
[Music]
cleanest bones [ __ ] this one I
don't think that it's just it's not it's
not sustainable in the long term you
know if Gary wants to come in here and
put on a show for the people I'm with it
I understand it I probably have a couple
of these bullets in the chamber but I
cannot just week over week be going at
these wings like a lion off of the kill
and then - I think I'm gonna freak out
the guests like just watch and Gary go
at those things from across the table I
was like Jim Joe so imagine Jordan Peele
I'm doing that in front of him he could
barely handle my little like mad thing I
don't like the way you did it like we
did all fast
he was scared and more of your favorites
the Ricky Gervais
the ELA Klein the Action Bronson the
Cara Delevingne
the guy petty through our convoy the
Rachel Ray
all right going forward I'm loosely
committed to a combination of the guy
fieri pick and pop and the Eric Andre
shoot first ask questions later keep in
mind that I am focused on the interview
my brain is fried I'm the zombie
apocalypse so there will be some
coloring outside the lines from time to
time okay
now that we're all in the same room
together a quick State of the Union on
hot ones frequently asked questions
first we know you want Gordon Ramsay the
guy is a little bit busy we cannot just
snap our fingers and all of a sudden put
him in the hot ones seat but we do read
the comments we do care about who you
guys want on the show so if ever the
opportunity presents itself you know
that we're on it number two you guys are
always like why don't you sell a box
with sample sized bottles of all the hot
sauces that you use there are a thousand
and one legal hurdles to that we are
trying not to get sued off the face of
the internet but we're always looking at
some way in which we could possibly make
that puzzle come together it is just
incredibly complicated but in the
meantime I do want to say thank you to
everyone who tracks down and supports
these hot sauce makers on their own many
of them are really good people I know
that you have a lot of fun doing it with
your friends or whatever so thank you to
the people who do that we are trying to
streamline it make it easy but it is not
easy it is it is very complicated and
then number three how much sauce you
guys put on the wings how do you guys
put the sauces on the wings I get this
tweeted at me like ten times a day
basically we put the sauces in a bowl we
put the wings and set bowls we toss the
wings and then voila
you have a wing with full coverage no
butter no watering it down we just go
straight out the bottle it's mainline
all right hot ones fans I appreciate you
giving me the time to defend myself
on how I eat my chicken wings I'm happy
I can clear the air on some of the
frequently asked questions that always
come up keep them coming thank you very
much for your support so far through
season four I - I baby who sees you me
who appreciates you me
[Music]
you